had to rely on men for like you said
financial support to be able to work to
be able to live essentially and as we've
come out of that yes it's been what like
40 50 years right as we've come probably
a bit longer no about 50 60 years to say
that and and
they had to rely on settling to be able
to get a man to be able to support them
so we are still shifting out of that
mindset where you you settle for
something that maybe isn't that great
because you have to be supported you
have to have this nuclear family
situation I grew up with two parents in
the house I grew up with a relative you
know two parents who were incredibly
functioning Society but I was suicidal
by the time I was 12 so it doesn't
having two parents doesn't blink at
least assume that you're going to be
happy like those statistics that you
read off it's not necessarily because
the kid had a single mother there's so
many different specific issues that go
into that poverty you know where you
live like different aspects it's not
just about having a single mother